it's rare that someone sues twitch and
it's virtually unheard of that
someone sues twitch and wins but
that's exactly what happened recently
with james varga
aka phantomlord who took twitch to court
four years ago
accusing them of unfairly banning him
from the platform
not only did the court side in his favor
and find twitch guilty
but this case has brought to light what
phantom lord refers to
as twitch's allegedly secret strike
guide
a list of rules regulations and
violations
that have not been made available to the
public
hello people on youtube like the video
subscribe to the channel
and hit that notification bell so you
never miss a story about
twitch ever again and if there's a story
you want us to cover here on don't at me
send a tip to tips at thescore.com so
back in 2016 phantom lord was banned off
twitch
after a report was published by esports
journalist richard lewis
accusing him of rigging the results of a
cs go skin gambling website
cs go shuffle he was also accused of not
disclosing the fact that he was
allegedly part
owner of that website at this point in
time cs go gambling was
extremely popular and it included a lot
of shady websites that allowed you to
gamble on matches and
casino games using your skins as
currency
obviously this was a huge problem
considering cs go attracted a young
audience many of whom were not legally
old enough to
gamble we've covered this situation on
this show before
cs go skins are a beautiful thing but
the gambling market surrounding them
is not so pretty for years now the world
of cs go skin gambling and trading
has been a murky one if you're not
careful you can get ripped off
really easily so phantom lord was banned
from twitch in 2016.
got it skip ahead to 2018 and that's
when he sued the platform
his primary accusation was that twitch
broke the standard partner agreement by
not giving him a
written reason as to why he was banned
from the site
quote significantly under the terms of
varga's contract
twitch was required to provide written
notice of any purported violations of
the contract
was further required to provide varga
with an opportunity to cure his
purported violations within 30 days
however twitch provided no such notice
much less
opportunity to cure these alleged
violations
end quote he also accused twitch of
essentially using him
as a scapegoat to deflect negative press
around this gambling situation
while also citing quote unsubstantiated
allegations
in order to ban him quote it is clear
from twitch's conduct that the stated
basis for suspension and termination
were an effort to deflect negative press
and scapegoat varga
allowing twitch to publicly decry
alleged gambling conduct and divert
attention from the fact that twitch
continued to knowingly allow
such conduct to continue on other twitch
channels
end quote twitch then essentially says
that's cool you can sue us sure
but you're only allowed to sue us for
fifty thousand dollars
see it says so right here in the
contract that you signed with us
but then in 2019 a judge partly ruled in
phantom lord's favor
saying that the 50 000 part of the
contract was
highly unfair we covered that part of
the story on this show when it happened
on september 27th judge curtis carnow of
the california superior court
ruled that a specific clause in
phantomworth's contract with twitch
was unconscionable the cause a 50
000 cap on how much he was entitled to
sue twitch for
because probably none of us are lawyers
here unconscionable in legal terms
means that a cause and a contract is far
too one-sided
it favors one party far more than it
favors the other
which is not really cool in contract law
the fifty thousand dollars is overly
harsh and unreasonably and unfairly
one-sided
there is no reason to limit varga to
fifty thousand dollars when he might
well be entitled to a much
much higher sum from a practical point
of view which i think is an essential
consideration
limiting recovery to 50 000 virtually
kills off the odds of a suit against
twitch at all
essentially the judge said that it's
asinine to cap the amount of money
someone is allowed to sue twitch for at
50 grand
especially considering lawyers fees and
the fact that no
lawyer would want to take this case on
for such a small amount of money
after that things died down for quite a
while that is until
recently on april 23rd when a 12-person
jury straight up ruled
in phantom lord's favor yeah phantom
lord
took twitch to court and won here's an
excerpt of the twit longer that he
posted after the fact
quote after nearly five years i am
grateful that a jury of my peers
finally held twitch accountable for its
improper tactics
against me including my suspension on
friday the jury found that twitch
breached its standard partner contract
acted in bad faith and committed fraud
by making numerous misrepresentations to
me
the jury also summarily denied twitch's
claims that i misrepresented myself as
an owner of cs go shuffle
the jury also flat out rejected that i
committed any type of fraud
the allegations and innuendos held
against my name can now be put to rest
end quote phantomlord also stated on
twitter that
quote twitch just asked the judge to
silence me from tweeting and talking
about the lawsuit end quote
so what exactly did the jury find twitch
guilty of
well according to the verdict the
following twitch did breach the
partnership agreement
and twitch unfairly interfered with
phantom lord's right to receive
partnership
benefits the verdict also states that
twitch did in fact give phantom lord
information regarding his
ban but that according to the jury
that information was false to be clear
though the verdict
also states that twitch was not
explicitly aware that the information
they gave him
was false essentially what the jury is
saying here is that yes
twitch did give phantom lord information
regarding his
band the representation of facts but
that either
all of or parts of that information
was false but the jury also found that
twitch was not explicitly aware that the
information they were giving him
was false now when phantom lord returned
to streaming on april 29th
on youtube he obviously talked about the
lawsuit
he said that all of the rigging
allegations were false and were proven
so and that he was never a part owner of
cs go shuffle which he was
also accused of the allegations about me
are just
straight up not true um i didn't scan
millions of dollars
i was not sitting there winning every
single pot um
it was not coded for me to win i have a
win-loss profit data sheet
as evidence that i gave to twitch during
this lawsuit um
that shows that i was negative 91
000 in profit now i interviewed phantom
lord and his lawyer for this story
they both said that while in court
twitch representatives
admitted to not looking into any of the
allegations
that they ended up banning him for there
was a jury
question where in california the jury
could ask questions
and they asked maestis did you
investigate the richard lewis plan
he answered the question the judge reads
it to him and he kind of
sighs and looks down and says no because
they didn't care
i mean that's the reality now during
that april 29th
stream phantom lord went on to say that
when he reached out to twitch
legal to ask about why he got banned
twitch legal
allegedly lied to him when i spoke to
anil he actually just kind of
meeting up for an event in in las vegas
at the time and so we just stumbled upon
the conversation and so he was just
casually telling us and then he looked
into it and told us was the fraudulent
subscribers
he said that he was told that by twitch
legal so by this
uh this individual named jordan gimble
and then when i emailed afterwards
directly to ask for more clarification
and get the you know the direct answer
and jordan gimble just lied to me and
said he didn't know and said he would
look into it one of the more shocking
things he talked about
during that stream was the fact that
twitch allegedly
in internal documents admitted to
banning him for pr
reasons which matches one of the
original allegations
that we talked about earlier they
straight up admitted
in the internal documents to banning me
for pr reasons they admitted
that they also shouldn't have banned me
at all
he went on to say that similar to his
original accusations
twitch allegedly admitted to using the
gambling situation
as an excuse to ban him the other
interesting thing to come from this
lawsuit is that we learned about the
existence of what he refers to
as twitch's quote secret strike guide
here's him talking about it in his
twitlonger quote also in this trial
twitch's secret quote strike guide its
undisclosed list of rules violations
was revealed and given the scrutiny it
deserved end quote
in the interview this strike guide is
described as a lengthy list of rules and
violations
and how to respond internally as a
twitch employee
if those violations happen according to
phantomlord and william his
lawyer this list is separated into rules
for users
random dudes like myself and rules for
partners aka the streamers that make
twitch
money and according to them twitch
requested to the court that
any documents relating to this strike
guide
be sealed from the public the reason
they don't want it public
is if they want to give james a pass or
give ninja pass or give sodapoppa to
pass
you know you as a streamer or you as you
know john q public
you look at this and say well wait a
second i would get suspended for it it
says right here on page three
and all of a sudden what does quit say
well you don't make us a lot of money so
we don't care
i found the document relating to this
request and yes twitch did ask the court
to seal any documents relating to the
strike guide from the public
citing confidentiality issues as the
reason and if you spent any time
watching twitch
you know that the platform typically
goes by a three strikes and you're out
banned off the platform sort of rule i
say typically because there have been
plenty examples of streamers getting
more
or fewer strikes before they're banned
making this so-called rule
more of a suggestion and also quite
confusing
quote twitch has identified an
overriding interest that supports
sealing that is
its strong interest in protecting the
confidentiality of non-public
commercially sensitive financial
information and trade secrets
relating to twitch's strike guide and
streamers compensation
information end quote now ultimately the
verdict awarded phantom lord twenty
thousand
seven hundred and twenty dollars and
thirty four cents i'm not sure if that
also includes legal fees
it's a far cry from the 35 million that
he was originally asking for
but still it's something setting aside
the money the more important thing to
talk about here
is that a streamer sued twitch and
[ __ ]
won that is huge now
it seems likely that twitch will need to
be more forthcoming about its
enforcement policy when it comes to
banning users
since it's clear to me anyway that vague
and unclear terms and policies
will not be tolerated anymore twitch's
vague policies
tos and inconsistent bannings have been
the number one complaint of streamers
since honestly i started doing this show
and if twitch now becomes more
explicitly clear about
all of these things in part due to this
court case
that's a [ __ ] huge w for streamers
everywhere as any streamer looking at
this so it forces the discussion that i
think we're having right now
which is what are the rules twitch and
if it truly is you can do whatever you
want at least tell us that
unfortunately that's all we know about
this lawsuit in this so-called secret
strike guide
if those documents are eventually
unsealed and made available to the
public
and if there's any interesting
information there we'll be sure to let
you know
on friday the jury found that twitch
breach
breached you [ __ ] dulled the jury
also
summit the jury also some alert
some some how do i say this word summon
some amer summarily there we go
summarily
the jury also similarly summarily youth
[ __ ] the jury also summarily denied
twitch's claims that i misrepre
i can't [ __ ] speak english today to
me it could be referring to the uns
unsubstantiated you forwarding idiot got
em
i am so sorry to whoever's editing this